okay
check check my check cbs sync test
check check my check today is
wednesday august 12th 2020.
75 degrees outside possible rain
oh yeah did i say today's wednesday
are we good cbs i i don't know yet
all right let me keep talking all right
um
see what we got here
okay they really need to see your lips
moving in
okay
i had uh dunkin donuts
and i had a caramel macchiato is my
favorite
caramel macchiato with a sash's bacon
egg and cheese
delicious
well we're about to start in a little
while
thank you guys for being here and
i hope all goes well yeah
everyone's have your questions ready
okay we promoted
let's do this right let's do this good
all right thank you
oh
okay
okay
so
[Music]
that makes your body
don't be right all the time
with
you me fail what's your favorite
[Music]
in order to move
foreign
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
the other places i'm just waiting to
break
[Music]
you ready
then
[Music]
three
hello
[Music]
come on come on
so
[Music]
oh
hey
[Music]
bye
me
[Music]
this is
so
[Music]
people who listen for the best
for your friends
[Music]
thank you
two three four five six
seven eight podium check one two
three four five six seven
eight podium check one two
eight this is a check of the lectern
in case please with me one two three
four
five six
[Music]
that you think
you ready
[Music]
as can be
let's do it
[Music]
oh
come on come on
[Music]
so
people who listen for the best times
[Music]
for your friends
with me
[Music]
oh
to everybody
[Music]
foreign
let's do it let's do it some more
[Music]
that you think
you ready
[Music]
as can be
let's do it
[Music]
huh
hello
[Music]
come on come on
so
[Music]
is
do you think i can afford
[Music]
i've
you're never gonna get my love
[Music]
tell me
you're never gonna make me cry
[Music]
now it's time
and try to find peaceful things
[Music]
i know we can make it work i know
we can make it if we try
[Music]
the little children of the world cause
they're our strong
just hope for the future of the little
bitty boys
[Music]
i know that we can make
do
i know we can make it work i know
we can make it if we try to die
[Music]
i know
hello
[Music]
people come together
[Applause]
is
i know
[Music]
so
my
you
[Music]
three
so
[Music]
number three
so
[Music]
bye
so
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
i wanna thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
thank you
[Music]
uh
sorry
[Music]
i wanna thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
uh
[Music]
so
really
[Music]
my dad
oh
[Music]
wow
are you
[Music]
people are playing
who's gonna raise me when i'm dead
[Music]
knows we could use a holiday baby
i'll give you the good night
[Music]
we were born and raised in new york city
fell
[Music]
[Applause]
if i drop yeah
[Music]
give me the good
oh
[Music]
boom
till the sun comes
[Music]
until our up are blown and put out
give me the good night
baby baby
[Music]
me
i know a place
[Music]
ain't no smiling faces
i'll take you there
[Music]
let
all right
[Music]
daddy
all right
come on little baby
[Music]
ain't nobody
uh
[Music]
i'll take you there
i'll take you down
[Music]
take me
i'll
[Music]
all right
oh
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
ah
[Music]
bye
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
ah
[Laughter]
[Music]
be
uh
[Music]
do
[Laughter]
[Music]
please welcome vice president joe biden
and senator
kamala harris
hush nut chow
[Music]
thanks for being here i wish we were
able to talk to the folks outside but
we're
keeping our social distancing and
playing by the rules
good afternoon everyone to me
and to uh come on listen exciting day
it's a great day for our campaign it's a
great day for america in my view
over the past several weeks i've had the
incredible privilege
of meeting and spending a good deal of
time with a group of talented women
leaders
all of whom are qualified to be
president
with each one the more i learned about
them the more i talk to them the more
impressed i was
even though i knew them before i want to
thank each and every one of them for
being part of this process
i look forward to working with them as
we rebuild this country
to get elected and once we are elected
god willing
a life-changing election for this nation
she's tough she's experienced
she's a proven fighter for the backbone
of this country
the middle class for all those who are
struggling to get into the middle class
security challenges our country faces
well aware well aware of all the threats
to this nation
and ready to respond to them and as a
child of immigrants
she knows personally how immigrant
families enrich our country
as well as the challenges of what it
means to grow up
black and indian american in the united
states of america
her story is america's story different
from mine in many particulars
but also not so different in the
essentials
she's worked hard she's never backed
down from a challenge
and she has earned each and every of the
accolades and achievements that she has
gained
many of them often in the face of
obstacles
that others put in their way but never
quit
and this morning all across the nation
little girls woke up especially little
black and brown girls
who so often feel overlooked and
undervalued
in their communities but today today
just maybe they're seeing themselves
for the first time in a new way as the
staff of
president and vice presidents
in her campaign in the primary camel
often talked about
what she referred to as the 3am agenda
about moms and dads awake late at night
in their kitchens
worried scared uncertain about how they
were going to take care of their
families
about how they were going to pay the
bills
about how they were going to make it
simply make it
growing up in scranton in claim on
delaware
i saw that struggle with my family as
well
kamal assault with hers as well and
millions of americans are living that
struggle as we speak
especially in this moment of crisis
especially with so many jobs lost
kamala and i both know
that all folks you're looking for as my
dad would say is an even shot
just give me a shot a fair shot
a shot at making it
and it'll be the work of our
administration
to make sure they get a fair shot
working families need someone on their
side in this nation
because they certainly don't have anyone
in the president
now on their side that's going to change
in the biden harris administration
it's going to be gratifying to see the
strong
enthusiastic reaction to senator harris
as our next vice president
you know it comes from people all over
the country it's already occurring
all over the country all ideological
views
all backgrounds events of course
we are predictable some of them it comes
from all over except
of course from donald trump's white
house and his allies
you all knew was coming you could have
set your watches to it
donald trump has already started his
attacks
calling kamala quote nasty
whining about how she is quote mean
to his appointees it's no surprise
because whining is what donald trump
does best better than any president
american history is anyone surprised
donald trump has a problem
with a strong woman or strong women
across the board
we know that more is to come so let's be
clear
if you're a working person worried about
whether or not you'll have a job to go
to
whether or not you'll be able to pay
your mortgage pay your rent
worried about the poison in the air you
breathe the water you drink
worried about your civil
which is under attack for this
administration
kamala harris has had your back
and now we have to have her back
she's going to stand with me in this
campaign and
all of us are going to stand up for her
on january twentieth twenty
at home and abroad
through four years of mismanagement and
coddling of terrorists
and thugs around the world not only will
america dig itself out of this hole they
put us in
we're gonna build we're gonna build back
and we're going to build back better
we have a public health crisis while
he's in court trying to do away
with health care with more than 5
million reported infections 165 000
people
dead and climbing as a consequence of
cover 19.
and still months later
no real leadership or plan from the
president united states
how to get this pandemic under control
no real help for the states and local
governments trying to fill the vacuum
of leadership from the white house no
real help
for children and educators for small
businesses and front-line workers
that hold in their ones holding our
country together
instead he's issuing
executive orders and making promises
that in the end will defund the social
security system
balance system
racial justice crisis donald trump seeks
only to inflame it
with his politics of racist rhetoric and
appeals to the vision
today is not only the day i'm proud to
introduce senator kamala harris as the
vice president today is not only
the day i'm proud to
of that terrible day it's also the third
anniversary
of terrible day in charlottesville
remember remember remember what it felt
like remember what it felt like see
those neo-nazis close your eyes
close your eyes clansmen and those clans
white supremacists coming out of coming
out of
fields carrying lightning torches
lighted
torches faces contorted
veins
remember how it felt remember how it
felt to see a violent
violent clash ensued between those
celebrating hate celebrating hate
and those standing against standing
against it
it was a wake-up call it was a wake-up
call for all of us as a country
as a country for me for me it was a call
to act it's a call to action
my father used to say silence is called
his complicity not original
not original to him but he believed it
but he believed it at that moment i knew
i knew i couldn't stop
trump
on both sides no president
attack everything that makes america
makes america america
i knew we were in the bible sold the
nation
that's when i to run i decided to run
and i'm proud now to have
now to have senator harris senator
harris at my side and my side because
she shares with the same intensity
same intensity she's someone who knows
she's someone
what's at stake the question is the
question is for all americans to answer
america is the answer
who are we as a nation are we as a
nation what do we stand for what do we
stand for
and most importantly most importantly
what do we want to be we want to be
you know you know someone who knows
someone who knows that the future of
this kind of future in this country
that only buyers replace in our own
imagination our own imagination
because there's nothing americans cannot
cannot
we do it together we do it together one
of the reasons i chose cons i chose
kamala
is because we both because we both
believe that we can define america
define america
in one word in one word possibility
possibilities
possibilities let's say it again let me
say it again possibilities possibilities
that's america that's america that's
what sets this nation up sets this
nation apart
said everyone that everyone everyone
everyone the ability for everybody for
everyone we mean everyone we mean
everyone to go as far
as far dream is big dream is big
that's hard work it's hard to believe
god's given ability will take them
when i agreed to service i agreed to
serve as president obama's running mate
he asked me number question number five
i've asked comma
the most important was the most
important one he said to me
what what you asked me what i want asked
me what i want
importantly most importantly i told him
i wanted to be the last person
the last person in the room before he
made before he made important decisions
important decisions
that's what i asked cam that's what i
asked kamala asked common to be the last
last voice in the room always tell me
this always tell me the truth which she
will
challenge my ass challenge my
assumptions if she disagrees
ask the hard questions ask the hard
questions because that's the way
that's the way we make the best
decisions for the american people
i got a chance to change his time to
spend some time in my home today
with common
friends they served as attorneys general
at the same time they took the same big
they took on the same big fights
together common california
bow here in delaware big fights
that helped change the entire country i
know how much beau respected kamal in
her work
and that mattered a lot to me to be
honest with you as i made this decision
so now we need to get to work
pulling this nation out of these crises
we find ourselves in
getting our economy back on track
uniting this nation
and yes winning the battle for the soul
of america
my fellow americans now let me introduce
to you
for the first time your next vice
president united states
kamala harris kamala flora is yours
there you go
thank you joe thank you joe
as i said joe when you called me i am
incredibly honored
by this responsibility and i'm ready to
get to work
i am ready to get to work
after the most competitive primary in
history
the country received a resounding
message
that joe was the person to lead us
forward
and joe i'm so proud to stand with you
and i do so mindful of all the heroic
and ambitious women before me whose
sacrifice
determination and resilience makes my
presence here today even possible
this is a moment of real consequence for
america
everything we care about our economy
our health our children the kind
of country we live in it's all on the
line
we're reeling from the worst public
health
crisis in a century the president's
mismanagement of the pandemic
has plunged us into the worst
economic crisis since the great
depression
and we're experiencing a moral reckoning
with racism and systemic injustice
that has brought a new coalition of
conscience
to the streets of our country demanding
change
america is crying out for leadership
yet we have a president who cares more
about himself
than the people who elected him a
president who is making
every challenge we face even more
difficult to solve but here's the good
news
we don't have to accept the failed
government
of donald trump and mike pence in just
83 days we have a chance
to choose a better future
for our country so
joe dr biden
thank you for the trust you've placed in
me
jill i know you will be an incredible
first lady
and my husband doug and i are so
grateful
grateful to become a part of your
extended family and ever since i
received joe's call
i've been thinking yes about the first
biden that i really came to know and
that of course is joe's beloved son
one of his beloved sons beau
in the midst of the great recession beau
and i
spoke on the phone practically every day
sometimes multiple times a day
working together to win back billions of
dollars for homeowners
from the big banks of the nation that
were foreclosing
on people's homes and let me just tell
you about bo biden
i learned quickly that beau was the kind
of guy
who inspired people to be a better
version of themselves
he really was the best of us and when i
would ask him
where did you get that where this come
from
he'd always talk about his dad
and i will tell you the love that they
shared was incredible
to watch it was the most beautiful
display of the love between a father and
a son
and beau talked about how joe would
spend four hours every
day riding the rails back and forth from
wilmington to washington
so he could make breakfast for his kids
in the morning and make it home in time
to tuck them in bed each night all of
this
so two little boys who had just lost
their mom and their sister
in a tragic accident would know that the
world
was still turning and that's
how i came to know joe he's someone
whose first response when things get
tough is never to think about himself
but to care for everyone else
he's someone who never asks why is this
happening to me
and instead asks what can i do
to make life better for you
his empathy his compassion
his sense of duty to care for others
is why i am so proud to be on this
ticket
and joe and i yes we are cut from the
same cloth
family is everything to me too and i
cannot wait for america to get to know
my husband doug and our amazing kids
colin ella
because whether i'm cheering in the
bleachers at a swim meet
or setting up a college room dorm or
helping my goddaughter prepare for her
school debate
or building legos with my godson or
hugging my two baby nieces
or cooking dinner sunday dinner
my family means everything to me
and i've had a lot of titles over my
career and certainly
vice president will be great but mamala
will always be the one that means the
most
and you know my mother and father uh
they came from
opposite sides of the world to arrive in
america
one from india and the other from
jamaica
in search of a world-class education
but what brought them together was the
civil rights movement of the nineteen
sixties
and that's how they met as students in
the streets of oakland
marching and shouting for this thing
called justice in a struggle
that continues today
and i was part of it my parents would
bring me to protests
strapped tightly in my stroller and my
mother
shamala raised my sister maya and me
to believe that it was up to us and
every generation
of americans to keep on marching
she tell us don't sit around and
complain about things
do something so i did something
i devoted my life to making real the
words
carved in the united states supreme
court
equal justice under law
and 30 years ago i stood before a judge
for the first time
breathed deep and uttered the phrase
that would that would truly guide my
career and the rest of my career kamala
harris
for the people the people
that's who i represented as district
attorney fighting on behalf of victims
who needed help
the people that's who i fought for as
california's attorney general
when i took on transnational criminal
organizations who traffic in guns
and drugs and human beings and it's the
people
who i have fought for as a united states
senator
where i've worked every day to hold
trump officials accountable
to the american people and the people
are who
joe and i will fight for every day in
the white house
and let me tell you somebody who has
presented my fair
share of arguments in court the case
against donald trump
and mike pence is open and shut
just look where they've gotten us more
than 16 million
out of work millions of kids who cannot
go back to school
a crisis of poverty of homelessness
afflicting
black brown and indigenous people the
most
a crisis of hunger afflicting one in
five
mothers who have children that are
hungry
and tragically more than 165
000 lives that have been cut short
many with loved ones who never got the
chance
to say goodbye
it didn't have to be this way six years
ago in fact we had a different health
crisis
it was called ebola and we all remember
that pandemic
but you know what happened then barack
obama
and joe biden did their job
only two people in the united states
died
two that is what's called leadership
but compare that to the moment we find
ourselves in now
when other countries are following the
science trump pushed
miracle cures he saw on fox news
while other countries were flattening
the curve he said the vice would just
poof go away quote like a miracle
so when other countries opened back up
for business
what did we do we had to shut down
again this virus
has impacted almost every
country but there's a reason it has
hit america worse than any other
advanced
nation it's because of trump's
failure to take it seriously
from the start his refusal
to get testing up and running his
flip-flopping
on social distancing and wearing masks
his delusional belief that he knows
better than the experts
all of that is reason and the reason
that an american dies of covet 19
every 80 seconds
it's why countless businesses have had
to shut their doors for good
it's why there is complete chaos over
when and how to reopen
our schools mothers and fathers
are confused and uncertain and angry
about child care and the safety of their
kids
at school whether they'll be in danger
if they go or fall behind
if they don't trump
is also the reason millions of americans
are now
unemployed he inherited the longest
economic expansion in history
from barack obama and joe biden
and then like everything else he
inherited
he ran it straight into the ground
because of trump's failures of
leadership our economy has taken one of
the biggest hits
out of all the major industrialized
nations
with an unemployment rate that has
tripled
as of today this is what happens when we
elect a guy
who just isn't up for the job
our country ends up in tatters
and so does our reputation around
the world but let's be clear
this election isn't just about defeating
donald trump or mike pence it's about
building
this country back better
and that's exactly what joe and i will
do
we'll create millions of jobs and fight
climate change
through a clean energy revolution bring
back critical supply chains so the
future
is made in america build on the
affordable care act
so everyone has the peace of mind that
comes with health insurance
and finally offer caregivers the dignity
the respect and the pay
they deserve will protect a woman's
right to make her own decisions about
her own body
root out systemic racism in our justice
system
and pass a new voting rights act
a john lewis voting rights act
that will ensure every voice is heard
and every voice is counted
the civil rights struggle is nothing new
to joe
it's why he got into public service it's
why he helped reauthorize the voting
rights act
and restore unemployment discrimination
and employment discrimination laws
and today he takes his place in the
ongoing story of america's march
toward equality and justice as only as
the
only as the only who has served
alongside the first
black president and has chosen the first
black woman
as his running mate
but as joe always points out this
election
is about more than politics it's about
who we are
as a country and i'll admit over the
past four years there have been moments
when i have truly worried about our
future
but whenever i think that there
is a reason for doubt whenever i've had
my own doubts
i think of you the american people
the doctors and nurses and front-line
workers who are risking
your lives to save others
the truck drivers and the workers in
grocery stores
in factories and farms working there
putting your own safety on the line
to help us get through this pandemic the
women and students
taking to the streets in unprecedented
numbers
the dreamers and immigrants who know
that families belong together
the lgbtq americans who know that love
is love
people of every age and color and creed
who are finally declaring
in one voice that yes black lives matter
all across this country a whole new
generation of children
is growing up hearing the cries for
justice and the chance
of hope on which i was raised
some strapped into strollers of their
own
and trust me it's a song you'll never
forget
so to everyone keeping up the fight you
are doing something you are doing
something great you
are the heroes of our time
and you are the reason i know we are
going to
bring our country closer
to realizing its great promise but to do
it we'll need to work
organize and vote like never before
because we need more than a victory on
november 3rd we need a mandate that
proves that the past few years do not
represent who we are
or who we aspire to be
joe likes to say that character is on
the ballot and it's true
when he saw what happened in
charlottesville three years ago today he
knew we were in a battle for the soul of
our nation
and together with your help that's a
battle we will win
earlier this year i said i do whatever
joe asked me to do
and so now i'm asking you to do the same
so visit joebiden.com to get involved in
this campaign
and vote because electing joe biden is
just the start
of the work ahead of us and i couldn't
be
prouder to be by his side running to
represent you
the people thank you and may god bless
the united states of america thank you
[Music]
just move
bye
[Music]
just move on up
[Applause]
[Music]
don't